let's uh let's jump into this first big
story we've got the uh the lead from
daily mail pentagon confirms the last
u.s troops and evacuation flights have
left afghanistan just after midnight in
kabul taliban take control of airport
and celebrate with gunfire as 20-year
war ends
there's there's so much to go through
first of all there really is you know
ian you just mentioned in the intro that
it doesn't feel like they've completed
the withdrawal they just stopped
withdrawing like stopped evacuating
people and just bounced out yeah the way
this even this statement this title that
you just read off this phrase is that
the last american troops left is that
the last ones that are going to be
leaving or gone now or is that the last
of all of them and then they're not
clear i still i don't know if people
they're very intentionally not clear
they won't let you know how many
americans are left behind they won't let
you know if they
decided to stay on purpose or
if they just didn't get in contact with
these people and then you've also seen
in the past like week or two you've seen
um
people saying on twitter like i let
somebody use my whatsapp to get a visa
at one point and now i'm getting
messages via whatsapp on their behalf
are they getting the messages or am i
just getting the messages you know these
kinds of things so it's really very
peculiar and it's hard to have any idea
what's going on the administration is um
not being transparent about it at all
and you can see that in the questioning
that they've been the questions they've
been taking and what's up with this
whatsapp thing someone let's
yeah or maybe it was uh i think it was
actually an email so a person put on
twitter i wish i had it uh but it's one
of these things that's on twitter so
it's not like you can figure out exactly
what the truth is um and the amount of
things that i've been getting from
people on twitter that are like here's
video
of a bunch of people getting shot inside
the kabul airport and it's like you know
i track through that person i attracted
that person to track through everybody
and then you eventually talk to someone
who is unwilling to go on the record and
you're like okay well this story is not
going to ever get out if i can't verify
who these people are and what's going on
so yeah it was somebody had said i let a
friend use my email address to receive
visa information i'm getting
notifications now about how it's time to
leave afghanistan are they getting these
notifications as well
so
i don't think it's fair to say the war
is over
because
well unless the press just stops
covering it entirely now and says yay
biden you did it that's clapping what
did i think the atlantic wrote the
article or was in the atlantic that
biden deserves credit not criticism i'm
like no he deserves criticism but uh the
reason i say it's not over is there
still i mean at least estimates here
from the daily mail 100 to 200 americans
are still in afghanistan as well as our
afghan allies right so do you think that
in the coming days that we're going to
hear news about american hostages i've
been wondering about this as well if
we're going to have repeats of these
kind of videos that we that we saw
previously you know these beheading
videos these hostage videos what's gonna
happen with that there were um there was
a clip that came out over the weekend it
was uh taliban soldiers in a tv studio
with a tv anchor and the anchor was
saying what the taliban told them to say
you know where everything's going great
i don't think we have any idea what's
going on and
the fact that we were engaged in a war
for this long in a place that has
destroyed empires before us was already
absurd
yeah that one i find particularly
humorous that people you know have
mentioned hey all of these empires kind
of faltered after afghanistan fiasco but
i'll tell you i'll tell you uh back to
the point about the war not being over
i'm watching this video clip of the
taliban walking through the airport and
there's like helicopters and planes it's
not just the military equipment they
received it's the civilian equipment
that's left behind by those evacuating
right that's all resources trucks are
something like 40 000 suvs they've
received now i'll tell you why it's not
over you think the taliban coming in i
don't care if it's the taliban or any
any uh government honestly although the
taliban would be markedly worse you
think they're gonna be able to maintain
the power they're going to be able to
maintain the infrastructure the economy
the natural resources
yeah homes are going to lose electricity
overnight how many days do we have and
tell us and the power goes out well also
they're already fighting with uh they
have ideological battles with this
other terrorist organization right now
yeah there was actually a clip um i
don't know
i hope i didn't tell you guys this
already
um but jack kerouac went on the william
f buckley show in uh i guess the 60s or
70s whenever it was and uh kerouac said
that he thought the vietnam war was a
conspiracy between the north vietnamese
and the south vietnamese who in his
words were cousins to get a lot of jeeps
in the country and buckley said well you
know i don't think it went too well for
them and kerouac said i don't know they
got a lot of jeeps yeah
so well they've got a lot of uh
american equipment have you seen the
before and after footage from like idlib
or
aleppo you know in syria and things like
that oh yeah i mean that was a while ago
a while ago for sure i remember you know
you're looking at these at these photos
particularly like aleppo and it's and
it's amazing this beautiful city and
there's like the colors oversaturated
because people are trying to purposely
evoke emotion and but you see the trees
you see the buildings the people and
then it's like the syrian civil war it's
rubble it's brown rubble
i don't know if it's gonna get that bad
in afghanistan necessarily but i i
person my personal opinion which is
based off of just what we're seeing
right now and a lot of things could
change because i can't see the future
i think it might get to that point
you you are you have no clear command
structure it's it's a group of people
who are fighting against the u.s and now
sure sure let me say this you have some
command structure right there's people
who are in charge
but in order to maintain a country and
let alone a city you need massive
managerial infrastructure which they do
not have so all of a sudden you're going
to have some dude and he's going to be
at a factory that makes i don't know you
know plastic lids or something whatever
they might need and he's going to be
like i don't know where any of this
stuff comes from and he's going to go to
the guy who works there and says oh we
order from this other company but no
one's there right now or something like
that the power company people are going
to leave
already yeah things are going to shut
down the guy who ran their central bank
fled right so now there's no like as
much as i don't like central banking
they're still like the system has been
gutted from the inside so what's gonna
happen where are people with no food
people are gonna go nuts and it's gonna
start breaking down and it's gonna get
brutal it does beg the question
what is america's responsibility to
nations that can't handle their own
governance uh we certainly stepped in in
europe all over the place but is that
the kind of thing that
people want from us and other countries
i think it's pretty clear that the
people in afghanistan don't want that
they don't want the us determining their
government structure or you know any of
that any of that kind of stuff so and
what is the i saw another um i wish i
could remember exactly who this was i'm
sorry that i can't but i saw somebody
else who was talking about how
um
america really is falling apart itself
at this point how can we take in some
200 000
uh
afghan refugees
who knows how well they've been vetted
we have people pouring across the
southern border we don't have any
control over that we have governors
fighting with the president over the
sovereignty of their own states and the
sovereignty of american borders
we can't properly educate our children
we can't figure out a cohesive strategy
for dealing with you know a global
pandemic that we have taken
responsibility for globally as well as
nationally what is it that we think
we're doing you know it's like we
constantly are talking about how much we
hate ourselves and how we are the worst
oppressors and we're you know this
privileged horrible bratty country but
we also take on everybody else's
problems and as much as the left will
talk about american exceptionalism being
a problem they're the most american
exceptionalist of all they think that we
can go out there smack ourselves in the
face wear h hair shirts and still save
the world
and that's what they expect
it's very weird to watch
yeah
i feel like uh
this war thing in afghanistan which is
never actually it's not a real war it
was never declared by congress it was
just a military action and it was only
to get bin laden there was no taliban
involved in any of this in the beginning
right taliban formed around it and then
then it was isis then it was al-qaeda or
it was al-qaeda in the beginning well
let's let's slow down taliban was 1994.
okay so it's been around forever so i
guess you know people different names
different places no the taliban formed
out of the out of the mujahideen and
they there was an afghan civil war that
was like expanding gaining more power
and then the u.s is like we're going to
go in and get them well we went in to
get al qaeda to get uh osama bin laden
and then that that got happened they
after a couple of years and then they
stayed four years yeah after a decade
and then the real reason we went and
came out was to build that country as a
in the eyes of america and get its
resources uh well that faltered
we have no no justification to fight i
mean
it's not to fight the taliban we were
never there to fight the taliban right
so that that is not something we will
ever it was look it was it was
colonization they call it nation
building i'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's colonized yeah it was
colonizing i don't know i'm not saying
that from some leftist college
blue-haired perspective of like they're
colonized no it's like literally like
it's actually what it is yeah the only
problem with colonization is when it
fails
and it can i guess
there's problems with colonization how
would you feel if china colonized new
york city
i think it'd be worse if they did a bad
job of it frankly it'd be bad no matter
what yeah it would be terrible no matter
what sure i guess i guess if china came
in and all of a sudden restored
everyone's civil rights i would say
western colonization is specifically bad
when it fails but i don't think you know
i think there's an argument to be made
that western colonization has actually
been
globally good but
you know i'm of the opinion that uh we
should at this point i mean to a certain
extent i would agree obviously but i i'm
also of the opinion of like maybe we
should mind our own business especially
at this point i feel that way as well
and i also feel that way in terms of uh
nations that clearly don't have any
interest in
in what we have to offer well there was
a poll i saw of of a bunch of different
countries pertaining to islam
and when it came to afghanistan
though these people did not share our
values in any way right there there were
people who were like i'll put i'll put
it bluntly we can sit here and say hey
look it was better with americans there
because of freedoms and economics but
these people genuinely hate
you know our way of living they they're
they're very very faith-based they're
very very tribal like literal literal
tribes right actually and there was a
poll where i think like a very large
percentage thought the death for i'm
sorry the the punishment for apostasy is
death like we don't have those things
and so we enter this country very
different way of living very different
clothes much much more advanced weapons
and we tell them from now on you live
the way we tell you naturally they're
not happy with that they're still not
happy with that
well and they shouldn't be uh you know
there's also this issue of how can you
bring you can't bring democracy and this
kind of liberty to a populist that
doesn't want it themselves
you know you can't just force that on
people because
that's like the thing you're saying
you're not gonna do and then you're
doing it in order to get them to live
your way that's not effective thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time